ready let's go
scream
coming from different countries we
always gone through a lot of ups and
downs finally we reached the top when we
got married all right ready
[Applause]
my god no
since ed and i got engaged i keep her on
her toes
it's never a dull moment with ed
[Music]
i don't really care what other people
think
i don't look at him as like he's 18
years younger than me i mean love
the love is there so that's what's
important
i've sold your boy's girlfriend that's
so crazy
you are mine forever
do you take this man to be your husband
what you love him for as long as you
both shall live i do
it is my honor to pronounce them husband
and wife you may kiss your bride
[Applause]
i've gave nothing but loyalty to michael
for five years there's that sex baby
but at this point i gotta do what i
gotta do for me what do you think about
me coming to canada
i understand why he has this kind of
trust issue well because you're out of
his league
she could totally get any guy that she
wants i don't like these girls i don't i
think they're influencing you in the
wrong way
not only are they whispering behind your
back but they're writing letters to make
false allegations against you to
homeland security i just don't know like
who would have tried to sabotage us
if there is a lot of people from the
family
they will make problems from us
i actually might be deported
are you really sure that you're going to
allow me to have that second one
[Music]
and i'm sitting right now i'm not
yelling and i'm making the coins
eastman wants a woman that's just gonna
sit there and keep her mouth shut and be
like okay i'm not that chick i'm gonna
go cause your ass is pissing me off
wow
i'm tired of your dishonesty
she was physically all over you you
think i'm having a relationship with
someone
are you a lesbian
why doesn't everybody think it's okay
for me to stay here and take all this
appeal you are overreacting
i need to pamper yuna every time
whenever you get mad
gonna do what free from me
get away from me forever
understand
[Music]
you